where is the manners compilation it is
mine by right stannis stannis stannis
stannis stannis
if we didn't press our claim for this
video our claim will be forgotten
we will not become a page in someone
else's history book stannis the menace
stannis the manus stannis the manus
stannis the manny's stan is the
manuscript stannis the manus status
day 134
still no stannis for x minutes videos
frowny face clears throat
stannis being the manus for x minutes
straight holy [ __ ] this is a lot of
[ __ ] requests stannis the goddamn
manners i've said the words damn yeah
the iron throne is mine by right
all those that deny that to my foes
joffrey renly rob stark they're all
thieves
they'll bend the knee or destroy them
time has come to
choose let no man claim ignorance as an
excuse he is a bastard born of incest
as was his brother before him yes
we have heard this story it's not a
story
it's the truth
how many girls how many men how many
women
the darkness will devour them all she
says the night that never ends
unless i triumph
i never ask for this
no more than i ask to be king
we do not choose our destiny
but now i'm the rightful king by every
law of westeros
when i sit the iron throne you'll be my
hand
you don't have the strength
it would kill you i'm not so easily
killed men have been trying for years it
is customary to kneel when surrendering
to a king
man's radar you've been called the king
beyond the wall
westeros only has one
king why else would the lord of light
have seen fit tomorrow face she needs
the rod she's my daughter
you will not strike her
i called in every maester on this side
of the world every healer
they stopped the disease and saved your
life
because you did not belong across the
world with a bloody stone man
you were the princess serene of house
baratheon
and you are my daughter
[Music]
and there's four less fingernails to
clean
fewer
for fewer fingernails to clean less
enemies for us
fewer
what
how many men do we have in the north to
fight him 10 000
fewer
what you were a hero and a smuggler
the good act does not wash out the bad
nor are bad the good
show too much kindness people won't fear
you if they don't fear you they don't
follow you
want your life going to be like here at
the wall with thorn in command
unpleasant i expect your bravery made
him look weak
he'll punish you for it
i don't punish men for bravery i reward
them
kneel before me lay your sword at my
feet pledge me your service and you'll
rise again as john stark lord of
winterfell
i heard it was best to keep your enemies
close whoever said that didn't have many
enemies
if i did not press my claim
my claim will be forgotten i will not
become a page in someone else's history
book
i'm running out of time sir davos
which means you're running out of time
i've rallied house peace breathing of
course
that was
what's good isn't that's good and house
hey
hey
they don't have enough men between them
to raid a pantry
in a real war
beside with the greater number wins nine
times out of ten
but surely there are other ways cleaner
ways cleaner ways don't win wars
i retreated from king's landing sir
davos if i retreat again i become the
king who ran your grace winter is coming
those aren't just the stark words that's
a fact
we march to victory or
we march
to defeat
but we go forward only forward
hundreds will die
thousands
i saw a vision in the flames
great battle in the snow
i saw it
[Music]
[Music]
come with me and take this city
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
do you have any last words
[Music]
who under your duty
[Music]
oh
you